come on get your lazy ass up all right
all right above already that's what you
get staying out partying all night I'm a
promoter I'm working I got like 18 000
followers you know who got followers
Jesus take your rude ass to work you
just curse what would Jesus say Jesus
would say shut the up this is my
house
too late as usual the cleanest place
I've got all day what the
[Music]
that counts just loved itself who's crib
is this man Steve Jobs Steve Jobs is
dead fool I mean his house died anymore
you got Miami Cleveland La
damn bigger city bro
oh my God we in LeBron's house LeBron
who James hey there don't go you are one
handsome he got a hologram
of himself just to give him compliments
you handled the decision to go to Miami
perfectly nah that's a cat
I need 10 G's by next week I gotta pay
for my daughter's school they on
vacation how about we throw the party in
the King's house
we gonna invite all the celebrities we
can make 10 times the money we can send
Destiny to preschool College whatever
tonight is our last shot looks like we
helped out
hi I see you there how are you oh
oh you're going to jail hi I'm
Peter is LeBron home
um by the way
black lives matter they do I posted two
squares on my Instagram respect
see
this is a really bad idea I wouldn't do
something like this unless I was
desperate
cracking bro
[Music]
get we done up the koala
you good what the just happened
your hairline is perfect anyone who says
otherwise it's just jealous it's God
[Music]